What's up guys!
I brought you out to the mountains today to show you a cool trick you can do with a lighter.
Now over the years I show you a lot of different ways you can start fires without using matches.
But some people in the comments say why not just pack a lighter?
It's small. It's compact.
And with the flick of the thumb you got instant flame.
And that is true as long as your lighter works.
Lighters are extremely handy tools for starting the fire,
but they do run out of gas and sometimes the get smashed.
You might find something like this on a hiking trail when you're hiking your camping spot.
If you do, it's not garbage.
The reason is because this striker wheel and flint will still make a spark.
Now a spark by itself isn't enough to start a fire.
We need a lot more than that.
But, it's enough to get us started.
Now the first thing to do is to find some kind of a flat board.
Relatively flat like this.
Because we're going to take the side of that striking wheel...
and run it slowly down the board like this.
The longer the board, the longer your stroke is going to be.
What this is doing is grinding off some of the ferrocerium inside...
and making powder you can use to ignite the flame.
Now, you don't want to go too fast...
because if you go too fast it'll make a spark and the whole thing will go up.
If you do just slow enough though you can scrape that ferrocerium rod into a powder...
without it actually igniting yet.
You want to do this about 40 to 50 times on a stick about 8-10 inches long.
Now by holding your letter sideways as you roll it as the dust forms,
it falls down and catches inside of the cap here.
So all we have t do now is turn it up right into whatever material or tender we want to ignite.
And then all it takes is a flick of the thumb...
we got ourselves a fire.
So look at that guys just like that we have ignition of our tinder pile.
While our little pile is smoldering here I'm going to make a little tinder bundle...
and we can blow this into a flame.
Now, in an ideal world you put your tinder pile inside of your tinder bundle before you lit it.
But since it's already going to be something like a business card just gently scoop underneath it...
And transferred over the file. Once that successfully transferred to the card...
Put your tender file over it and just gently roll it over.
And you can see how nicely those embers are formed.
That's going to build up into a fire very very quickly.
And now this point all we have to do is add a little bit of oxygen...
and we've got ourselves a fire.
There it is.
How cool is that?
But, if you have something like a paper towel or Kleenex this is going to work even easier.
Just make a pile of your dust right in the center of the paper,
and when you give that a little flick the entire paper will catch on fire.
You can use that as your tender instead.
Just like that we have an instant fire,
and we need to get our fire pit really quickly.
A very simple trick and it does not get much easier than that.
Thanks so much for joining me for this experiment.
And I'll be looking for you in the next video.
Talk to you then.
[Music]